this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
thanks for joining us here noon everyone
i'm alex backus we begin with that
breaking news right now in the far east
valley crews are on scene
of a deadly house fire off owens and
hollywood jim muller just arrived on
scene he's there now with the very
latest hi joe what can you tell us
alex fire officials just briefed us here
giving us the latest information on what
happened here at this fire unfortunately
two children
have died in this blaze one was two
months old and the other was
two-year-old two
young boys we'll give you a live look
here at the scene the fire investigation
is continuing fire investigators just
took over this scene to look into how
this exactly started
now you're looking down that is
caddington avenue that's where the fire
was at a home here on the left side of
your screen we can't show the home
because of this investigation
now those two children unfortunately
were found dead inside that home one man
was taken to the hospital
now reports of smoke came in to dispatch
just after 10 o'clock this morning
now that clark county official just
explained to us they believe this
started in
the front of that home here and spread
to the bedroom in front of the home
where those two children were
now again they are looking into the
cause of this fire they're still trying
to figure out what exactly happened
inside
there is a lot of family members here
waiting for answers as well the streets
in this neighborhood are blocked off
with this investigation i spoke to
some neighbors just a short time ago who
are obviously completely surprised by
this many
saw the commotion happening just after
10 o'clock this morning but this was a
big response out here a lot of
fire officials police there was a
helicopter overseen here
but this investigation at this hour is
continuing again two boys
two young children unfortunately
perished in this fire the investigation
will continue but we'll of course
get updates when we can and we'll bring
you the very latest here on air and
online i'll send it back to you